we're very excited to welcome our two
new hosts yay
how does it feel to be an official
member of the talk and it feels like the
first day of school
in many aspects i could barely sleep
last night
we got our best outfits on it felt
really surreal so today it gets really
real
due to the pandemic surge in la new
hosts amanda klutz and elaine welteroth
spent their first day on the job from
home i think it's gonna make us
all raise our game on this show
today also marked the first day back for
sharon osbourne and carrie anna naba who
spent the holiday at home recovering
from covet 19.
i'm feeling really fine now i went
through
all the symptoms headache i ate body
ache
i still can't smell very much or taste
very much i mean either i can't taste or
smell the worst part about i think going
through covid was the fear
factor and just trying to manage the
fear of amanda i thought of you
a lot of course amanda knows the
devastation of this deadly virus
her husband broadway star nick cardero
lost his life
after his months-long battle back in
july he left behind
their now 18 month old son elvis what
would nick say to you
about this new job and how proud would
he be he would be like baby
he was my ultimate cheerleader i know
he's right beside me today
through this nick is there spiritually
and physically
amanda keeps his ashes close to her
inside this ring
do you have the ring on that was made
with me oh yeah
oh wow it's beautiful i feel like he's
with me every day
and i i absolutely love it and cherish
it and it'll be handed down to elvis one
[Music]
day